في مؤتمرها العالمي السنوي للمطورين عن
جهاز جديد طال انتظاره
ابل
وهي عباره عن نظاره ذكيه مزوده بسماعات
تمزج بسلاسه بين العالم الواقعي والعالم
الافتراضي وفق ما ذكره مدير الشركه
التنفيذي تيمكوك وذلك بتصميم يختلف عن
الاجهزه المشابهه المطروحه في السوق وبحسب
كوك يسمح الجهاز الجديد للمستخدمين بان
يروا ويسمعوا ويتفاعلوا مع المحتوى
الافتراضي كما لو انهم يرونه في الواقع
حولهم ويتم التحكم بالجهاز باستخدام
اليدين والعينين والصوت معا
وتصمد بطاريه الجهاز الجديد مده ساعتين
وسيكون متوفرا العمل المقبل في الولايات
المتحده بشعر ثلاثه الاف
و499 دولارا
ويعتبر سعره اعلى بكثير من اجهزه مشاهده
الواقع الافتراضي المتوافره في الاسواق
حاليا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات